manifesting is using the power of your
mind to change and create the reality
you experience and this is why I'm so
passionate about this practice this is
the book manifest seven steps to living
your best life by Roxy nafusi Who I'm
interviewing in this week's episode of
Deep dive the weekly podcast where every
week it's my immense pleasure to sit
down with entrepreneurs and academics
and creators and other inspiring people
and we find out how they got to where
they are and the strategies and tools we
can learn from them to help build a life
that we love now over the years this
idea of manifestation has gotten lots of
mixed reviews with some people saying
it's like the work of the devil and
other people absolutely swearing by it
and saying it's completely changed their
life if you are a skeptic read my book
like the person I want to read this
almost the most is the skeptic at its
core it's about self-worth because the
kind of biggest secret of manifesting
let's say is that you manifest what you
subconsciously believe you're worthy of
receiving and so my conversation with
Roxy nafusi is all about breaking down
exactly what is this manifestation thing
what are the seven steps to manifesting
your ideal life and what are the
practical actionable things that we can
do that a science fact that can help us
use the power of manifesting to achieve
our own goals what it really allows you
to do is become who you're supposed to
be it allows you to unlock your
Limitless potential and learn to be
authentic and have the freedom to be
yourself and learn to love yourself and
that for me is the real gift of it
hey friends so before we get into the
episode I've got some very exciting news
that I'm finally able to share with you
and that is that I have written a book
now if you've been following the podcast
for a while you'll probably know from
some of my conversations with authors in
particular that has been quite the
journey over the last three years this
has been the single hardest thing that
I've ever done in my life but after
three years it's finally here and I'm
delighted to announce that my book feel
good productivity is now available for
pre-order it's going to be published
later this year and you can find a link
down in the video description or if you
head over to
feelgoodproductivity.com all one word uh
you can check out the website and the
website is absolutely sick now the
central idea for the book came from a
realization that I had while I was
working as a doctor a few years ago and
trying to juggle everything with my
YouTube channel and my business and I
kind of realized that the secret to
productivity isn't discipline it's in
fact joy and sure hard work and great
and willpower and determination and all
of those things are good in small doses
but for most of us they tend not to be
the sustainable route to consistent
productivity but I realized through a
lot of experimentation and then diving
into a bunch of research that actually
the secret to productivity that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
is to find a way to make your work feel
good to find a way to make it feel
energizing and enjoyable and if you do
that you'll be more productive in your
work but you'll also have way more
energy to give to the other things in
your life that matter to you and this
isn't just my own personal experience
but it's an idea that's been validated
by a bunch of studies in the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience as well and
so the writing process of the book over
the last three years has involved
reading hundreds of research papers
interviewing academics and experts in
the fields of like psychology and
procrastination and motivation and
spending years trying to condense it
into a format and cut out all the fluff
and try to do it in a way that's like
engaging and actionable at the same time
so that's what the book is about it is a
science back guide on how to do more of
what matters to you in a way that feels
enjoyable and meaningful and sustainable
and if you enjoy this podcast then I can
basically guarantee that you will love
the stuff that's in the book there are
nine chapters each chapter has six
different experiments in it that you can
try out in your own life and so there
are 54 different experiments strategies
that you can apply to your life starting
from as soon as you read the book and
the idea is that you apply these and you
see if they work for you and over time
you'll build your own feel-good
productivity system now if you do decide
to pre-order the book then that would be
awesome because firstly helps me out and
secondly I think the ideas in this book
can be genuinely life-changing and if
you pre-order the book it will be
delivered straight to you on release
date later this year or to your Kindle
or your audible account and I'm
narrating the audiobook by the way or to
their hardback hardback version of the
book If you prefer to read physical
copies of books and if you do pre-order
then please do be sure to save your
receipts because I'm going to be
announcing a bunch of really exciting
pre-order bonuses exclusively not only
for people who pre-order the book and so
final thing before we get into the
episode is just want to say a massive
thank you to you guys by watching the
videos by subscribing on social media by
listening to the podcast you have made
this book possible without you guys
supporting the channel and everything
that I do there's no way penguin would
have come knocking and been like hey do
you want to write a book and so I'm like
this has been like such a rewarding
experience and I could not have gonna
come to this point without your support
so I just wanted to say massive thank
you from the bottom of my heart for that
so that's it from me do check out the
book If you like at
feelgoodproductivity.com it'll be linked
Down Below in the podcast description
and the show notes as well for now let's
get into the podcast episode itself
alright Roxy thank you so much for
coming on the show oh thank you so much
for having me so you are according to
Forbes the manifestation queen or words
to that effect and you've got these
books manifest seven steps to living
your best life and a manifest to Dive
Dive deeper yeah um which I've done
fantastically Sunny Times better and all
and all the fun stuff so unsurprisingly
I was hoping we could talk a little bit
about manifestation amazing
um so so my starting point for
manifestation is I Tried reading the
secret and I got about halfway through
it and I was like okay reasonable
reasonable reasonable and then they
started talking about how you can cure
cancer through manifestation and stuff
like that and then it sort of turned me
off the topic but I've recently started
to take some forays into the world of
spirituality
um also did an interview with our mutual
friend Tara Swartz and we talked a
little bit about manifestation being
actually legit and not just some woo
thing so that's kind of my starting
point so I'd just love to ask you all
the questions I have about manifestation
um we also put it out to our podcast
Telegram community and we've got a bunch
of questions from from the listeners
just trying to understand this whole
idea of manifestation how does that
sound that sounds great and honestly I
kind of love speaking to Skeptics about
this and I I always say if you are a
skeptic read my book like the person I
want to read this almost the most is the
skeptic fantastic okay it's a good place
to start then so um what is
manifestation and why does it have such
a kind of controversial connotation
so manifesting is using the power of
your mind to change and create the
reality you experience and I think that
you know manifesting over the last few
years although manifestation by the way
has been around for a century you know
longer like this is if you think about
you know Napoleon Hill Think and Grow
Rich that was in 1917 it was like one of
the first books of manifestation there's
been so many great philosophers and
thinkers speaking about this uh subject
so it's not new but over the last few
years it's kind of had this Resurgence
and because of things like Tick Tock
it's become this real Trend now the
problem with when something becomes a
trend is it becomes really devalued and
people start to use the term manifesting
in a way where it's not really
understood or it's not used properly and
so people will start using it in general
conversation so they'll just be like oh
I manifested you know this this or I
manifested that but not using the word
actually as it's meant but just using it
as this kind of casual term someone told
me their daughter the other day was like
um I manifested my Zara arriving and she
bless her she's only young like she's
she doesn't know what it what it means
but it's really it's reached such a vast
audience now that people are just
throwing the word around
and so for me I feel like I'm almost the
pr of manifesting trying to do damage
control because uh you know it makes me
sad in a way that such a meaningful and
important practice is being devalued in
this way and there are so many
misconceptions around it
um that are gonna put people off and to
be honest if I didn't know about the
practice and I came along late and just
heard about the trendy parts of it I
wouldn't I wouldn't be into it
um and these misconceptions include that
it's uh magical there's something some
really magical woo-woo aspect to it
um other misconceptions are that it's
about material possessions and I think
that really you you know especially in
In A Book Like The Secret that was part
of it it was this but it was a different
time then in the 80s and that was part
of the appeal then we are in a different
time now but it was you know manifesting
cars and money and things and and things
that are just much more material and
this is actually a lot more meaningful
than that
um another misconceptions are that you
know it's only for this kind of
particular person it's maybe perhaps for
this kind of gen Z generation or someone
that is female and young and you know
spiritually inclined whereas actually it
is a practice that is absolutely for
everybody men women old young whatever
demographic
um your own wherever you're from yeah so
I guess for me the skepticism comes from
like as you were you were talking about
like hearing people just throw the word
out oh I'm manifesting it throwing that
up kind of without without like any any
yeah without anything as any anything
associated with that
um so what actually is manifestation and
I guess also how how did you discover it
like how did you end up becoming the
manifestation Queen
so what manifesting is is it's a
self-development practice and to me all
of self-development and inner healing
for under this manifesting umbrella so
manifesting is essentially a way of
living and for me my book isn't just a
guide to manifestation but it's a life
guide you can kind of live and breathe
these steps that I that I lay out and
manifesting is essentially at its core
it's about self-worth because the kind
of biggest secret of manifesting let's
say is that you manifest what you
subconsciously believe you're worthy of
receiving
okay you manifest what you
subconsciously believe you're worthy of
receiving and so
um
so at its core is is self-worth and so
the kind of healing Journey required for
all of us to be able to feel that we are
worthy of love and happiness and joy and
abundance you know it's such a profound
one for us all to go on and this is
really about it's a practice about
becoming so empowered and so full of
self-belief that you then make things
happen and you are able to reach your
goals and even be able to set your
intentions and overcome challenges and
embrace gratitude and live a better life
hmm
okay so I'd love to dig more into the
details of what that means but I guess
first how did you end up getting into
this oh so
um funnily enough I actually when I now
I look back on it my dad is uh was
teaching me about quantum physics and I
was like five so I definitely feel like
he kind of he must have started that
seed in me
um but growing up I kind of had truly no
self-worth it was it very I was not a
happy upbringing or you know my teens
were all full and I won't go into any
details about it now but it was not a
good time and by the time I was then 18
I discovered cocaine and alcohol and
cigarettes and I quickly fell into
addiction and that
um really kind of controlled my life for
the next 10 years and by the time I was
27 I was just about to turn 28 it was
May 2018. I had hit one of my many Rock
bottoms but this was a particularly bad
one a pretty particularly low point and
I called a friend of mine and I said you
know I really don't know what to do
and she said you should listen to this
podcast on manifesting
and I was like oh my God I'll try
anything so I was like okay I'll listen
so I listened to it and something in me
just clicked and I went home and I
started researching the practice and
kind of learning everything I could and
what actually happened was two weeks
later on June the 7th 2018 a man named
Wade messaged me on a dating app and on
the 7th of June 2019 a year to the day
our baby boy wolf was born
um and after that I after Wolfie was
born I pursued a career I wanted to be
an inspirational speaker and basically
use all my years of pain to help others
but the way I was changing my own life
was through manifestation and so I
started organically kind of saying to
what was quite a small audience at the
time
um do you guys want to learn about this
thing I've been doing and I started
doing workshops which turned into
webinars over the pandemic and I'd come
up with my own seven step formula and uh
yeah then here I am I mean that's a long
more work involved in between but here I
am so what was it like on
in May 2018 when your friend said you
should check out this podcast on
manifestation what was it about
manifesting that click that clicked
inside for you um it was that my
self-worth was driving everything and I
knew I had no self-worth so on this
podcast they said
that your self-worth was determining
your outcomes and the reality you're
living in and I was like huh okay so
actually maybe I am manifesting but in
the wrong direction I have such low
self-worth and I have so much
self-loathing that I keep attracting
these negative
things into my life and I'm keeping
myself stuck in this dark place and
actually I'm going to stop being the
victim of my own life and I'm going to
take responsibility and I'm going to
take charge
what do you mean by I had low self-worth
or had self-loathing like what sort of
stuff were you telling yourself I have
it's not something I really talk about
often but I have had severe body
dysmorphia disorder for like my whole
life so I've been convinced that I'm an
absolute monster that nobody I thought
that nobody should look at me that I was
very embarrassed if anybody would it was
just a severe self-hatred
um and despising who I was and so that
you get the inner critic that can come
in and out but mine is there or has been
I mean I think you know so grateful to
be on the side of this but my inner
critic was there every moment of every
day
um and controlling my life really
controlling what I did and so for me the
reason I was taking so much so many
drugs is because it was the only time I
had an escape from that kind of monster
in my mind it was so Savage
um and it would stop me doing anything I
mean I wouldn't go after opportunities I
would you know I would socialize
differently like every everything that I
was doing and every the way I was
perceiving the entire world and every
relationship I had within it whether
that was friendship or romantic was
different because I hated myself so much
that sounds very terrifying yeah it was
dark it you know it's really tough and
so
when I found manifesting and this is why
I'm so passionate about this practice
that it really does heal it's not just
that oh great you get to manifest you
know a promotion or this or that you
know those things are the cherries on
top they're great but what it really
allows you to do is become who you're
supposed to be it allows you to unlock
your Limitless potential and learn to be
authentic and have the freedom to be
yourself and learn to love yourself and
that for me is the the real gift of it
yeah it really sounds like you're you're
like really passionate about it yeah I
really am so in in your experience of
teaching this stuff for I guess five
five years now what other starting
points do people come to manifest
manifesting with like if someone's
listening for this now and maybe they're
not they don't relate to the idea of
like self-loathing or thinking they're a
monster what other thoughts might be
going through someone's mind that
something like manifesting could help
with I think really anybody that is
looking to make a positive change in
their life you know to whatever degree
that might be so they might just think
you know I'm stuck in a job that I
really don't enjoy and I want to find I
want to do something different but I
also want to have the confidence to be
able to make that leap or make that
shift it might be that they're in a
relationship that makes them unhappy or
that they're searching for that you know
their soul mate it might be that they're
feeling quite lonely and they're looking
for they want to have a new friendship
group or be more open to making new
friendships
um it might be you know could anything
anybody that is listening that thinks
I want to take control of my life I want
to feel hopeful and excited for the
future I want to unlock my potential I
want to do better I want to be my best
you know it really is for anyone
thinking any of those things or anyone
that even you know there's a lot of
people that come to manifesting actually
that say to me they'll read the book or
they'll say do you know I realized I've
been always been manifesting you know
I've always had that kind of like I've
always felt lucky I've always felt like
good things happen but actually now I
understand the real process behind it I
can apply it better
and therefore get more out of my life
it's May 2018 you've discovered this
podcast and you've you realize that whoa
like the outcomes I'm having are kind of
dependent uh based on my self-worth and
because your self-worth was through the
floor it was like the outcomes that you
had were weren't ideal yeah and then you
said you went on this journey where you
started reading and discovering and
applying it to your life so what did
that what did that Journey look like
over the next let's say a few months
so immediately after one of the first
things I started doing was listening to
affirmation playlists so one thing I
realized early on was that a lot of this
was about reprogramming your belief
system and the beliefs that you had
about yourself and
so uh we all hold various beliefs and
beliefs are thoughts that have been
repeated so many times that they become
so they become a belief so let's say
you're told from a young age
um
that your or or somebody makes you feel
unlovable and you have formed that
belief that you are unlovable or that
you are not smart you know there is at
school often do there were lots of my
friends who used to say you know I'm
just not naturally smart so I really
have to work harder than everyone else
okay so they just end up having this
belief about themselves that they are
not smart and so what happens is when we
have these various beliefs about
ourselves or the world these belief
systems uh determine how we perceive the
world they determine how we perceive all
of our experiences and the meanings we
attach to things and so they really have
a big influence on the life that we're
living and what we then create for
ourselves
and so the first step is ready to
change these beliefs that we have but
changing your beliefs isn't easy because
it they are they for many of us we've
had them for decades
um but it is possible to change them and
to form new beliefs and the reason we
can do this is because of
neuroplasticity which I'm sure you would
have talked to Tara about you know which
is your brain's ability to form new
neural pathways through repeated thought
and action so I kind of understood this
and I also understood at the same time
that
um when we whatever we say to our say to
ourselves our subconscious determines to
be true so if we are saying I'm not good
enough I'm not worthy our brain believes
that to be true as if we say to
ourselves I am enough I am worthy I'm uh
I'm you know capable of anything I put
my mind to our brains will believe that
to be true
and so if we could say affirmations
enough or if we could even listen to
affirmation playlists which is where you
listen to let's say a meditative piece
of music while there's uh these kind of
affirming statements playing you could
start to reprogram what you believe if
you do it regularly enough all right so
that's cool yeah it's amazing so it's uh
something that I started straight away I
sort of Fallen because our brain's most
susceptible to this positive messaging
as we're waking up in those first few
moments as we're falling asleep and when
we're in a meditative state so I started
doing that straight away
um and then I started immersing myself
in self-development as a whole so at
this point I was I'd kind of heard about
manifestation but really I wanted to
delve into all things to do with
self-help I wanted to just better myself
and so I would just listen to all kinds
of podcasts and read books and I
sometimes say I like brainwashed myself
with self-help and then using all the
information that I was getting I started
to
formulate these seven steps so you're
listening to these affirmation playlists
you're diving into the world of
self-help and how did that like
how how did that change your life
um
firstly I'll say that it changed my life
in every way imaginable I mean my life
now
um it's completely different I mean in
every way you know there's no kind of
inch of my world that's been left
unturned by the positive effects of
manifestation
um but I think the journey isn't is was
not one that was overnight although some
things like I met wage like straight
away that was amazing but then what
happened was
um after that was not that suddenly my
life was perfect after a few months
actually what happened was I've became
pregnant with my son I was he had to
suddenly give up on my addictions I
would get went into a very dark place
um but actually I had this I started to
look at my past I started to look at
what was where all these wounds were
coming from I started to understand
myself better I started to dream about
the future I started to imagine that
there was a future that um was better
and that was happier and then I started
to work towards that and that wasn't
just a uh just about visualizing it but
actually firstly figuring out what work
I would need to do to get myself to
those goals like being a speaker or you
know being an author or any of those
goals I had but also start to fall in
love with myself and be able to have
that amazing thing called self-love
what is what does loving yourself
actually mean
it means to me
um
being able to
okay this is for me if I could like
summarize like what it feels like to
love yourself it's an ability to be able
to walk into any room exactly as you are
being yourself and leaving that room not
worrying what everyone else thinks of
you
because you have this absolute ability
to
respect who you are to love the person
that you are to feel proud of who you
are
um that you are have the freedom and
liberation of being yourself
but further than that it's also about
being able to honor where you're at day
to day it's about being able to check in
with yourself constantly and know what
how you're feeling physically
energetically mentally and offering
yourself what you need whilst also
simultaneously being able to honor where
you want to be tomorrow and it's finding
that amazing balance
I'm reading a book at the moment called
love yourself like your life depends on
it by Kamal ravacan oh yeah which is
which is interesting it has some
affirmation type stuff in it and
yeah the affirmation stuff is
interesting like I've I've dabbled with
it over the years and I've always found
it helpful but then I've never stuck
with the practice but I've never tried
the whole thing of listening to a
playlist
um in the morning or the evening I think
that's it's such a good one it's a
really easy one to do as well especially
if you fall asleep to it but um
affirmations really do work and I
recommend them you know I recommend them
in the book and all my workshops
whenever I'm talking to clients
um they're such an easy tool to use and
you can use them throughout the day to
replace that inner critic because you
can only have one thought at a time so
when you're let's say you're going into
a meeting and you're thinking oh my God
what if I up or what if I say the
wrong thing or whatever it is you can
use an affirmation if you have like some
at your disposal like ready to go of I
will do my best and that is enough or
I'm calm I am at peace I'm safe you know
you just say an affirmation you
immediately stop that negative thought
pattern
um you know from selling to Loop or to
get bigger you know how it can and
um but I also love them even just to
start the day today will be an amazing
day I can't wait for the opportunities
ahead of me I can handle anything that
comes my way you can use affirmations
throughout the day just to make you feel
better I'm I'm already feeling uplifted
just by you saying that just like yeah
that's a great way to start today one
thing that I often start my journaling
morning journaling with is uh today is
going to be a great day and it's just
like because it otherwise it's a blank
page you know what today's gonna be a
great day blah blah blah and then it's
just a nice yeah gets the thing flowing
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by huel I've been a pain customer of
huel since my fifth year of medical
school since 2017 actually since before
I started my YouTube channel and I first
started using heal because my life was
pretty hectic I was juggling lots of
different things like medical school and
exams and trying to sort out publication
points for my future like doctor job
applications and alongside I was running
a business I was building an app and I
was trying to maintain some semblance of
a social life and so he actually came in
really handy for that if you haven't
heard of it it's basically a meal in a
shake that contains all of the
ingredients that are essential to thrive
it's got a perfect balance of protein
and carbs and fats and vitamins and
minerals and these days the heel black
edition is my absolute favorite comes in
nine flavors salted caramel is my
personal favorite and the heel black
edition is particularly good because it
is a higher protein version than the
heel original it was the original that I
was using back in 2017 but the Black
Edition came out a few years ago changed
the game because it's 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get Hench and so I'm keeping an eye on
like my protein intake and it's so nice
that I can get that high protein hit as
the first thing in the morning heel is
also very affordable it comes up to one
pound 68 per meal for a 400 calorie meal
which is actually way cheaper than most
of the other options on the market and
certainly way cheaper than other you
know even Standalone protein shakes like
I said I've been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. my friends literally make
fun of me as to how much fuel I have in
the house and they're like what you have
all this heal I'm like yeah it's
actually so good so if you're interested
in signing up for heal then head over to
heal.com forward slash Deep dive and if
you use that URL a it helps us out
because then they're Keen to sponsor
more episodes but B you get a completely
free t-shirt and a free Shaker with your
order so that is hopefully an incentive
to use fuel.com forward slash Deep dive
and actually I interviewed the founder
of huel Julian Hearn on this very
podcast in the very first season so you
can check out that episode if you like
it's got rave reviews really good
episode all about starting and growing a
business so anyway thank you so much
Hill for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you could invest it into a pie where
someone is generally a pro or someone in
their bedroom who just loves the markets
has already done all the homework for
you also very excitingly there's a new
feature that they've added to the app
which is a daily interest on your
uninvested cash these interest rates may
go up or down over time as the economic
environment changes but the cool thing
is that you get paid out every single
day if you're into that sort of thing
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali it will give you a totally free
share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading212
into your respective App Store so thank
you so much trading212 for sponsoring
this episode
Okay so we've mentioned these seven
steps a few times and I know you've got
this book manifest seven steps to living
your best life
um but I guess for someone who may not
have come across the book before and
obviously you know we'll put a link down
in the show notes and in the video
description to the book and book number
two which people can check out and so I
wonder if we can just run through these
seven steps at a high level and then I
guess me and listeners can can imagine
what steps we would have to do to apply
these into our life and we'll just take
it from there okay perfect yeah cool so
what is Step number one okay so step one
is to be clearing your vision so
essentially you can't get to where you
want to go if you don't know where it is
you are headed so at the very beginning
of your manifesting journey I ask people
to look at where they want to be six
months one year or five years from now
um and really be able to get some
clarity around that now when it comes to
being clear in your vision
um I always say that people two things
are kind of required of them the first
is vulnerability and the second is
courage
um it takes it's quite a lot to really
be honest with yourself about your
dreams and your goals and what you
really really want and that does require
you to be vulnerable because you know if
I think
back at you know in the beginning of my
journey or even now if I think about
some of the things I really want like my
deepest desires it can feel really scary
and it can feel like oh God is it really
even possible or
um what would someone else think of me
if I did that or if I wanted it or would
my family think if I was changing
careers or you know all these different
things that that you know are quite
scary so it really does require that
sense of vulnerability to be honest
about what you want and what you want to
change and then it requires courage to
allow yourself to actually say it out
loud or put it on a vision board or
dream about it
um
and so I kind of kind of for me this is
it's such a great place to start and a
great place of reflection and I think
even in itself just this step is such a
nice opportunity for people to reflect
and analyze and look at their lives and
what is it that's working for them right
now and what do they want to change
um and to kind of support this step
there you can do visualization
meditations and uh vision boards so it's
kind of the two main things now
visualization is such a powerful tool
and there's lots of Neuroscience about
it and again you would have spoken to
talk with Tara about this but
um when you repeatedly visualize your
goals your the subconscious parts of
your brain starts to Prime itself to
reaching them so it filters out any
unwanted information and it seeks out
opportunities that are aligned with it
but interestingly I had something
recently from um it was Dr John
um de martini and he was saying that
when you have values when you're
whatever your highest values are what
your highest priorities are that are
authentically aligned uh with with who
are aligned authentically with you with
what you really want and that means that
they're not the desires of someone
around you but what you actually want
and what you and your soul really values
and prioritize it your subconscious
actually filters out information the
same way I really I never knew that
before but actually even with you if you
have a very clear goal that is aligned
with your actual desires and that's why
you need to be vulnerable your
subconscious will seek out opportunities
that are aligned with it and so you will
feel that you're manifesting that well
but actually it's because your
subconscious is finding those
opportunities for you whereas if you
have a goal that you don't actually
really want let's say you kind of think
you should want to but it's not really
what you want your subconscious isn't
looking for those uh opportunities that
are aligned with it and so you think oh
God it's not working
and so being able to actually be really
honest with yourself about what you want
is so key in this step as well
um so this is step one okay question a
few questions on this yes um
how ambitious are these is this Vision
allowed to be like as as ambitious as
you can go but like I'm not
realistically gonna say you know six
months from now I wanna I wanna be a
billionaire right like this there's some
level of where we're Beyond which it
it's unreasonable look for me personally
I don't think you should be putting
things down for no reason like if you're
thinking
um if you're putting
this isn't uh like I said this isn't
about materialism and this isn't about
um being ridiculous this is about
thinking what do you actually want and
feel you need to make your life better
what do you actually in your heart of
hearts at your deepest core think you
need a billion pounds in six months
because that to me is more like fantasy
that's like oh yeah out on a
billion dollars right that for me
doesn't really come from a meaningful
Soulful place which is what this
practice is based on but if you had a
goal that okay I want this many
subscribers in six months and I want to
I want that because my I have a real
purpose for why behind that I want to
entertain or teach or Inspire this many
more people that that number can be as
high as you want because anything can
happen and so this isn't this is really
important I think that this isn't just I
want to be on a yacht by this time next
year that might be something that is in
your deepest core fire but really be
honest with yourself like if that is in
your deepest core and if that's your Top
Value and why you know what is the
purpose behind the things that you want
okay yeah that makes sense
um one one other one other question I I
I have is
how how do you know if it's what you
truly want versus it's what you think
you should want based on like society
and stuff like are there any questions
that you ask people that get at the
heart of like is this truly what I I
want
yeah I think you know I I speak about
that kind of more in the second book but
I really encourage people to kind of for
me I would just sit and do like a
journaling practice around this okay
because once anyway once you start this
kind of Journey of self-love and
self-awareness it's going to get easier
to be able to understand what is
actually your own opinion and what is
someone else's but being able to sit
with yourself and do something like a
vision board is an opportunity for you
to really have this sacred experience
where you can think what actually when I
think about it makes me feel excited
fulfilled
um at peace content you know we know we
get a feeling if we think about
something in the future and someone says
okay you can do this and you think oh my
God and it just makes you feel so good
and there's no worry or anxiety attached
to it when there's something we're
thinking about something else but that
also that excitement also comes with
this feeling of worry or anxiety or you
know apprehensiveness you know explore
where is that coming from you know is
that because it's not really aligned
with what you want
um you know and asking yourself
questions it's like when did I first
want this it was I influenced by
somebody else telling me this was a good
thing what do I think this thing will
really bring me because for example do I
think it's going to bring me
um you know validation from my family
validation from my peers validation from
the community do I think it's just going
to bring me status or power or do I
think it's going to bring me actual
fulfillment and joy and contentment
because that's the search here not the
not the former so you mentioned
visualization and vision board
um
what is a vision board like if I if I
wanted to turn this into a vision board
like how how would I like practically go
about it
so there's a step-by-step guide in both
books
um that make it really easy for people
to follow but essentially it's a visual
representation of what you want your
life to look like so I recommend people
um making it this kind of experience for
themselves getting a large sheet of card
and splitting their life into different
categories and then writing down exactly
what they want to happen within a
certain timeline so you write the future
date on the top and then you write it
down and so
for me these can be visual some people
do you use photos and cutouts of
magazines Etc but most people I see
doing that are not making vision boards
they're making mood boards so I often
get tagged in pictures and they all look
very pretty but there's no specifics on
there okay okay a vision board has to be
really specific and so for me my
personal vision boards are just bullet
point writing okay so I just put bullet
points of everything I want to happen in
each category of my life and I go big
you know I go really big on these things
and
although I always say you know
manifesting isn't Magic it definitely
feels magical because there are things
that you know I because especially
because now I just I so know that these
steps work I so know that these things
that seemingly are un impossible at the
time become possible I really go big on
these dreams that I have and to watch
them
um happen and you know manifest
themselves into my life is extraordinary
so I I love vision boards hmm so it
doesn't need to be like a physical
cut out because that's the thing that
stopped me from doing it on a physical
piece of paper Okay so not like just on
your notes on your phone on a physical
feature but just bullet points just a
bit specific so if you want like say
someone wants a book deal like a witch
publisher or how far along in the
process do they want to be by the end of
the year
um if you want to be on someone's
podcast exactly whose if you want to
have
um a promotion exactly what do you want
your salary to be uh what do you want
the job title to be what kind of Boss do
you want what kind of uh colleagues do
you want to have to be working with uh
what do you want their culture and the
office to feel like
um do you really want to be as specific
as you can um
that's great like I think
with all the stuff that I've been you
know as part of my book a lot of
research around like goal setting and
things and there is just so much
evidence that actually
setting goals is remarkably helpful yeah
absolutely it just sounds kind of basic
but like yeah if generally if you ask
people what they actually want it's
really hard to answer that question it
takes a lot of introspection to be to
sit down and be like oh yeah damn yeah
well you know what do I actually want
six months a year or three years from
now yeah and then when people wait
around for something to come along and
make a change in their lives
but you can't make change until you know
what that change actually is or what you
want it to be and so this really is
about taking control of your life and
being able to go okay I'm gonna set some
actual clear goals and intentions to
give myself some direction to move
towards
what do you think about the idea of
setting goals that are within your
control versus outside of your control
like for example I can control
putting out three videos a week but I
cannot control getting 10 million
subscribers because that's a an outcome
that relies on other people to do stuff
so like do you draw a distinction
between I guess input goals and outcome
goals I would say that for me personally
if there is you have those two
distinctions of like I want to do this
many videos a week but you also want to
have 10 million subscribers I would
personally be putting both of those on
uh on the vision board
because
okay let's say this let's say that for a
personal example at the start of 2022 my
book hadn't come out yet manifest I mean
I didn't even know if it was any good
nobody nobody had read it there was
nothing to say that it would even do
well
but I had put down things like
um I'd put Jay Shetty podcast on there
I'd put
um Sunday Times bestseller American
publishing deal American morning TV uh
multiple languages Cena airports I mean
I went big okay every single one of
these happened now Jay Shetty me putting
him specifically okay on my vision board
that requires him to take action but
what can I say I put it on and it
happened
okay so there is I think
and this is where the Skeptics may
switch off
but everything in the universe is made
of energy okay we are all energy our
thoughts emotions who we are the sky
above us this chair we sat on and I do
believe that
um
there is some energetic force greater
than ourselves that with the power of
manifestation you tap into and things
seem to happen and so there is this kind
of amazing sudden synchronicity that
begins to happen in in your life and
these things that you wanted seem to
appear not completely by magic I mean
look Jay Shetty saw the book that I had
put out let's say okay and so of course
because I had made a book and because it
had been successful he invited me on but
I also reached out to Jay and said I
want to be on your podcast okay so it
wasn't like
completely fluke so there's this balance
of things being like drawn through this
energetic force and you having to take
action and do the doing which is step
three align your behavior
um but with something like 10 million
followers
you know the internet's a mad place you
could make one thing that goes
absolutely viral or multiple or suddenly
one particular person just
you know shares your Channel or whatever
it is and then these numbers suddenly
start to grow so I mean I would be
putting it all down the only thing I
wouldn't be putting down is something
like win the lottery okay because that
is just luck that is absolutely nothing
there's nothing you can do about that
like you have no influence over those
lottery numbers okay so manifesting the
weather to be nice on my wedding day
probably a bad idea probably because I
can't really do anything
yeah okay but with almost everything
else even outcomes that are outside of
our control yeah there is stuff that we
can do we can align our Behavior with
the outcome that we want yes and so to
become the sort of person that Jay
Shetty would have on their show yeah you
write book that's actually good and then
you reach out to him and yeah be nice
and it's like you know then these things
are not as Out Of Reach as they might
initially seem yeah
sick okay
so I'm going to try vision board
um visualization you mentioned their
visualization meditations like what is
it yeah I just like I have some of my
website manifesting meditations YouTube
has Tans find a voice that you like
um and do a guided visualization
meditation
first guided then you might eventually
feel that you can just do it on your own
um I love doing them before bed I still
do them before bed I just sink into my
future self what I want into the feeling
of having it uh the feeling of gratitude
around it
um yeah I think that's so powerful
what do you think of the uh you know
there's that whole thing that the Buddha
used to say which is all says which is
that um desire is suffering and there's
there's people who say that when you set
goals or desires that's a contract that
you're making with yourself to suffer
until you hit that particular goal yeah
I'm totally antique there oh really yeah
because uh so step five is Embrace
gratitude without caveats and this is
about I call this The manifesting Sweet
Spot knowing what you want whilst being
entirely grateful for all that you
already have
okay so this isn't about setting these
goals and then obsessing over them okay
to me that's actually got this really
desperate low Vibe energy this is about
setting your goals doing what you can
day to day to you know step two remove
fear and doubt step three align your
behavior
um overcome obstacles step four you know
overcome tests from the universe but
actually them being able to sink into
this real vibration of gratitude having
this
incredible and real appreciation for all
that you already have and being in an
abundant mindset and in that way you're
able to enjoy the journey and able to
surrender to the journey
um trusting in that step seven trust in
the universe and that's about
surrendering to the journey that gets
you there knowing that when you do all
these things when you're able to
you know be clear on your goals work on
yourself healing Journey align your
behavior which means taking action
overcome tests persist through
challenges Embrace gratitude and turn
Envy into inspiration once you can do
all these things you trust that you will
reach your goals but you don't need to
try and control every single step of the
way you know in every movement that's
going to lead you there there has to be
this element of absolute surrender and
Oprah talks about it often know what you
want then let it go and that's the kind
of like sweet spot and the magic you
know if somebody asked me what was my
real
um like secret ingredient to my own
personal manifesting Journey you know I
manifest so powerfully
it is that I anything I want I'm able to
let go of I never obsess over wanting
something because I have this like real
faith and ability to come back into the
present moment hmm
yeah there does seem to be The Sweet
Spot
um like
setting a destination
in order to set your direction yeah but
then kind of forgetting about the fact
that like this is or rather not fixating
on the fact that that's the destination
is actually just focusing on the journey
and enjoying the journey and exactly
kind of taking it one step at a time
imagine that you're going on holiday and
you're so excited to get to where you
want to go
if you were just fixated that I just
need to get there and some people are
like this before holiday oh I don't want
to travel I don't want to I don't wanna
have to do all the like headache of
packing and getting to the airport and
oh the long flight and I just need to
get there and that whole journey is so
unenjoyable for them and they feel they
cannot relax or actually just like be in
it until they get there and then there's
another type of person that is like oh
my God I'm so excited I get to and the
minute they finish work you know on that
Friday and they're going on a Saturday
they are so in it they're so grateful my
holiday starts now I'm gonna get to the
airport three hours early because I love
it I'm so excited and on the plane
they're you know getting their Journal
out and watching films and that for them
the whole experience becomes part of the
holiday rather than just waiting to get
to the destination
yeah
yeah that's nice I like going on a hike
like the point of going on a hike isn't
really to get to the destination it's to
go on the hike exactly you can't really
go on a hike without a destination in
mind otherwise you're just wandering
aimlessly so it's like
you have your destination but then you
enjoy the hike exactly
man okay I need to try to visualize this
um visualization meditation and also the
vision board
um okay step two what is step two
step two is remove fear and doubt so
fear and doubt is the culmination of all
your insecurities low self-worth
limiting beliefs um all the things that
are holding you back and
the kind of two things really standing
in the way of you and your goals are
these things fear and doubt
um and for all of us we have buckets of
it really I don't think there's anybody
that could say I don't have any and
that's why that in that question of um
you know if I would say a fearing down
weren't standing in your way what would
you really want you know that's how you
really get to the Crux of what you want
because fear and doubt are so powerful
that they don't even let you think about
what you want yeah you know in the first
place it feels almost painful to be like
oh no I could never get like yeah I'm
not even going to think about it because
it's never going to happen exactly
um and so the kind of removal of the
sphere in doubt is this is the healing
Journey required this is why manifesting
is a self-development practice and this
really is about you know there's kind of
two parts of it one part of it is for
you know really being able to heal those
wounds
um of our past is working with
therapists counselors
um healing as you know anybody that can
help you to understand yourself better
and so I really am kind of pro external
support but there's also things that you
can do day to day to start to reprogram
the way you feel about yourself and so I
have so many tips in the book about how
to change your language the way you
speak to yourself
um journaling how to change your
perspectives using affirmations
meditations how to cultivate more
self-love so this is really an ongoing
process
if you're in that okay step three step
three is align your behavior so this
really is all about taking action this
is about uh create being the change you
want to create
and uh being able to step outside your
comfort zone take risks
um do the things that you know you need
to do to get to where you want to go so
for a lot of us we have goals we kind of
already in in our hearts know what we
need to do to get there but we don't do
them because we are influenced by our
fear and doubt so let's say we know we
need to you know if we wanted to grow
our business we would probably have to
be on social media more we would have to
reach out to more clients we would have
to ask for help but we don't do it
because we're scared and we're waiting
to feel ready enough or for something
opposed to be perfect enough to post or
whatever it is holding us back
but lining your behavior is asking you
to kind of transcend that fear in doubt
and be able to act as your future self
would so I ask people in this step to
really think about the person that they
want to become their higher self their
best self their most empowered self and
think how would that person behave what
decision would they make what would they
do and then start to do it and so I use
this term fake it till you become it
you know which is my Twist on fake it
till you make it
um and so uh yeah this is really about
this kind of like forward momentum and I
always say look there's no substitute to
hard work you can't think your way to
success this is about absolutely taking
action doing the work that's required
hmm
yeah all of this stuff is just so so so
resonating with me even like out outside
of the language of manifest outside of
the language of manifesting
it's
like even even if we take away all of
that all of the spiritual component this
is also evidence-based in terms of you
know totally set a goal recognize the
emotions that are getting in the way
that are holding you back from that goal
take action it's such an obvious process
like when I say the seven steps I'm like
of course it works like excuse
my language of course it changes your
life like how could it not yeah like
they're so practical and accessible and
I do think that's why this book has been
so successful because it really isn't
anything well you don't need to be
spiritual to enjoy this book
this episode is very kindly sponsored by
Shopify Shopify is great Shopify is an
easy to use all-in-one Commerce platform
that literally anyone can use to start
and grow and scale a business from zero
to like multi-billion dollars in Revenue
Shopify lets you sell basically anything
online or in person or across social
media and they power millions of
businesses in over 175 countries we've
been using Shopify for the last several
years a to sell our physical digital
product planners in the essentially
product line and we're using Shopify to
build a tech brand that we're working on
the behind the scenes and the website
and stuff as we speak again everything
powered by Shopify and it's great it
just makes the whole system so easy it
plugs into the Fulfillment options it
plugs into sort of the delivery options
it's just like so handy to have Shopify
as this all-in-one platform to manage
literally all aspects of our Commerce
business so if you're considering
starting or growing your Commerce
business then head over to shopify.com
forward slash deep dive and that URL
will let you sign up for a totally free
trial so you can try Shopify out and see
if it Vibes with you so thank you so
much Shopify for sponsoring this episode
okay so we're on step three align your
behavior yeah step four step four is
overcome tests from the universe so for
me and
it's listening don't freak out about the
word university
you know for me what I believe is that
when we're on our way to our goals the
universe this energetic Force whatever
presents you with uh obstacles to
overcome on your way and these obstacles
really ask of you to
they're kind of testing how worthy you
really think you are so if for example
your
uh trying to manifest your soul mate
okay so let's say that you've had this
vision board person you've written down
all the qualities you want in there what
kind of relationship you want to have
you've worked on feeling you know that
you're worthy of love then you've
aligned your behavior by going on dating
apps or allowing your friends to set you
up you go on a date and it's amazing
and you think oh my God this is
incredible this is the one
and then you don't hear from them for
four days
and then they text you four days later
and they say hey what's up that to me is
a test
okay the test is how worthy do you
really think you are of the kind of
relationship you deserve because anyone
that's texting you four days after a day
is really not that interested okay I
think we can all agree on that but for
somebody that is
still in that place of fear in the doubt
that still feels that actually I don't
know if I'm worth more than this they
will say they will continue engaging
with this person spending their energy
on that person whereas somebody that can
actually say no I know I'm worthy of
More Than This will be able to say no I
see this is a test and I'm going to say
no and close the door and create more
energetic space for the right thing to
come
and so you can apply this to kind of any
kind of situation but you have to keep
asking yourself is this
obstacle is this test allowing me to
show my worth you know am I am I able to
overcome it and show that I believe I'm
worthy of more
um or do I kind of fall at the hurdle
and it's also you know for me this step
really is about it's not only about that
which is really essentially just about
not settling for less than you deserve
but it's also about how well you're able
to deal with any challenge that comes
your way any rejection any obstacle
because you always have a choice you
allow it to say to you oh see I knew it
wasn't going to happen for me I knew it
wasn't right and then you give up and of
course then you never manifest your
goals or you're able to say no what can
I learn from this what meaning can I
take from it what's the lesson here how
can I persist through the challenge and
so for me I really believe and I I I I
truly believe that this is the for me
the my favorite step because
manifesting is about real life and there
are challenges and this allows me to
deal with those challenges with so much
more ease and so much more resilience
and so much more strength because I just
see it as an opportunity I know I'm
going to up level on the other side
whenever I'm going for a period of time
where things are tough I'm like
something good is coming on the other
side there is a reward on the other side
and I do believe that the Universe
rewards you after hardship
I want to steps five five to seven step
five is Embrace gratitude without
caveats my mum really summed this stuff
up for me so growing up in Arabic she
used to say this phrase to me which
translated as for every thanks you give
you get a thousand in return and so this
for me is is really all about
understanding that having a real
appreciation for life
um puts you in this abundant mindset and
you attract more good into your life the
life gives you more things to be
grateful for but this really also is
just about improving your overall
well-being your mental health everything
I mean there are so many
um so many studies about the power of
gratitude and the effects it has on our
sleep depression anxiety overall
well-being and even Dr Joe dispenza did
that Amazing Experiment where he got
participants to practice gratitude three
times a day for four days in a row and
their immune system strengthened by 50
so gratitude really is so so powerful
and it allows us to really enjoy the
journey while we're on it
um Step six is then turn Envy into
inspiration so Envy comes from this
really scarcity mindset which says you
have something and that might mean less
for me and you know for well we all feel
it especially you know I don't know how
many small business owners you know are
listening but gosh you know when you're
putting your life in Soul into your
small business and then you see a you
know a competitive brand you know doing
well it's really hard you get that
feeling of of Envy but this is about
firstly being aware of your Envy when
it's coming up and understanding how you
can transform it into inspiration
inspiration is the antithesis of envy
and comes from this really high
vibrational abundant mindset that you
have something and I can have it too
okay so I encourage people to uh and
give people tips on how to be more aware
and know how they can turn that into
inspiration and even go further by
really celebrating other people's
success because other people's success
show us what's possible hmm
amazing and then and then step seven is
trust in the universe so this is all
about looking for the synchronicities in
your life the coincidences uh you know
you're thinking about someone and you
know you they text you or if I had to
happen to me yesterday I was really
thinking about someone in a yoga class
and I had quite a strong emotional
thought about them I'd I'd actually felt
bad about the way a conversation had
ended with them like two years prior
and I just really came up in this yoga
practice
20 minutes later they walked fast for me
oh and I was like there it is again you
know so it's it's looking for those
synchronicities and allowing them to
show you that there is some energetic
force that is always listening to you to
your thoughts and your actions
um and they do influence what is
happening around you and then it's about
just trusting that if you do all the
rest of the steps what you want will
come to you all right those are great
stuff thank you um so we've talked about
the seven steps and I'm super inspired
I'm going to try out the um step one
later today actually and then they do
the visualization meditation and also
make a start on some kind of vision
board what mistakes do you see people
mistakes do you see people make with
manifestation I guess in your you know
in your last five years of of teaching
this stuff
uh so the main thing I think is just
that thinking it's about visualization
or a vision board or visualization
meditation so people often
say to me I'll get a message saying I've
been doing it every night and nothing's
happening and I'm like doing what every
night you know like what do you mean
doing it because manifesting isn't a
ritual it's not an IT thing that you do
every night
um or every morning it is a way of
living these stats you live and breathe
and when you understand the process but
I think that people get under the
impression or make the mistake obviously
I did ask that person if she'd read the
book she had and just said but
um you know it's uh there's this idea
that there is a ritual that you can do
and that will be enough to attract
things into your life and it's just not
the case but the other mistake people
make I think is becoming too obsessive
and desperate for with their goals and
that's where they keep their vision
boards out in front of them they become
like
they I become obsessive over it and I
think that is this really jarring energy
which I think stops you having from it I
think everybody actually will have an
experience that they know they can see
this for themselves when you have been
so desperate for something how often
does it not come to fruition and I think
it's that desperation that really blocks
it from coming in I think actually you
need that openness and surrender and
Trust to actually Attract it in that
last step yeah got it and then beyond
the sort of vision board which is you
mentioned you don't maybe every year and
then you look at it every six months or
so yeah do you have another any other
formal goal setting or review kind of
process in your life
so for me personally I just have a
journal where it might be once a month
or once every two months or it might be
with my team that I'll be like okay we
need to set some new goals or get some
things that we want to manifest but to
be honest with you this year
um I I manifested so many of the things
that I wanted and I feel so content and
I feel like I've been still on a healing
Journey throughout this whole time you
know even who I am now to six months ago
is so so different
um but I'm not constantly setting myself
new goals because actually I'm in a
chapter right now of my life where I'm
just really enjoying
being and just enjoying things as they
are you know there was that great quote
which is um remember the time you ha you
wish for the things you have now yeah
and I really for me that really stuck
with me and I was like yeah like wow I'm
really right now living my dream so it's
not that I'm now like okay on to the
next I'm just in a space of enjoying it
but when the time comes new girls
amazing proxy thank you so much I think
that's a good place to end this um any
any final words of wisdom for people who
might have might have listened towards
you know to the entire length of this
episode so far oh well that's a thank
you if you did listen to the end
um I know just that you know you do
really have so much more power than
um I think any of us give ourselves
credit for we we have the power to make
remarkable and transformative changes in
our lives amazing thank you so much
thank you so much all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye